there are places on earth whose power
cannot be explained whose energy flows
from depths beyond history local shamans
say this lake was formed when the earth
split open revealing a pillar of flames
reaching to the sky quenched only by
deepest floodwaters
this gave the lake its name standing
fire or by call led by calls sheer
dimensions are astounding it is the
deepest lake on earth with a depth of
over one mile it is the world's largest
containing one-fifth of all freshwater
on earth and as the world's oldest has
been here for 25 million years but
numbers don't explain its mystery for
thousands of years indigenous people
have worshipped the spirits of nature
here at shaman rock somewhere deadly
corrosion a lot evolutionary jetty in
universities national revolution Nadia
so you radically bred cough duo flood
aqui esta she right opposite an
interception Emily road Emily Lake
Baikal is also home to over 2,500
species 80% of which can only be found
here but recently the threat of
overfishing and pollution have put this
unique ecosystem at risk
protecting Lake Baikal has been a global
endeavor since 1996 when it was declared
a UNESCO World Heritage Site in recent
years the Russian government has stepped
up its efforts to preserve this treasure
that belongs not just to this country
but to the entire world
[Music]